hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about vitamin D in
relationship to why everyone all of a
sudden is deficient in vitamin D so I'm
going to give you the basics of it and
then I'll get into the why so here's
some basics number 1 our bodies need
about 1200 international units of
vitamin D per day ok that's a general
amount it might go up or down depending
on several factors one is your stress
level because obviously if you're more
sick or more stress you're going to need
more the foods that have vitamin D would
be cod liver oil that's why your
grandmother recommended that fatty fish
butter cheese cream raw milk very high
in vitamin D but most people get it from
the Sun because what happens is the UV
lights convert cholesterol on your skin
just turn that cholesterol into a
chemical reaction that occurs to your
liver and kidney that then eventually
makes vitamin D so your body will make
vitamin D from some in the interaction
of the cholesterol on your skin okay so
that's how we get it vitamin D is used
to support bone so in a child you could
have if you're very deficient you can
have this thing called rickets which is
very weak bones the bones start bending
so there is a connection between vitamin
D and bone I'll get into the specifics
in a little bit the immune system highly
sensitive to vitamin D so if your
vitamin D deficient you can have immune
problems but vitamin D is is not really
like a vitamin it acts like a hormone is
a hormone it's a pre hormone so it turns
into a steroid it's a type of steroid a
lot of times when you get vitamin D from
the pharmacy they'll give you the wrong
kind and they make it synthetically you
want a more of a natural form all right
so now why all of a sudden is everyone
deficient in D that's that's weird well
there's a couple reasons for it number
one MD is only recently been testing
vitamin D previously they haven't really
looked for it so that could be one
reason
number two people don't go out in the
Sun as much especially as you get older
you're going to stay away from the Sun
because of the scare of skin cancer and
things like that so people are not going
out in the Sun kids don't go out in the
Sun as much we're mainly in an office
behind the computer also low cholesterol
diet remember Sun converts the
cholesterol in the vitamin D so we need
cholesterol so if you're a low
cholesterol medication or you're going
on a low-fat diet olestra diet it could
be that could be a culprit you don't
have any raw material to build vitamin D
or it could be a lack of something
called bio I've done videos on this bile
is the detergent that breaks down the
grease it is a fluid from your liver
that breaks down fats specifically fat
soluble vitamins vitamin D is a
fat-soluble vitamin without bio you
can't absorb vitamin D so it could be a
digestive liver issue okay and that's
why if the doctor gives you so much
recommend so much vitamin D per week
like I've had people come in they're
taking fifty thousand milligrams like
way more than you would need once a week
not every not spread out but once a week
and if they don't have bio they're going
to get a Vitamix called vitamin hyper
hypervitaminosis vitamin D that's
actually vitamin D toxicity that's too
much vitamin D and the symptoms for
vitamin D toxicity would be the calcium
starts clogging up your heart your lungs
the kidneys you get kidney stones you
get all sorts weakness in the muscle you
get really you have a lot of fatigue so
just because you are deficient doesn't
mean you need to go overboard and go the
other direction go way over the edge so
you need bile to absorb vitamin D and
make it work and the last thing is not
very known but stress specifically the
stress hormone called cortisol cortisol
is the adrenal hormone the stress
hormone
that competes for other steroids like
this in other words this stress hormone
goes in the body and it's received in a
receptor and if there's too much stress
hormone there won't be enough receptors
for vitamin D so now vitamin D doesn't
go in there because vitamin D is a
steroid so is cortisol
they're both steroids they're almost
hormone like so when you have a lot of
cortisol or stress you block the ability
to absorb vitamin D and honestly I think
this is probably the more the most
common reason why people have low
vitamin D levels is stress so we have
that and also the flight or flight mode
the adrenaline rush lack of sleep oh my
gosh it's incredible so no wonder we
have low vitamin D levels so that's
that's some basics on what vitamin D
does and now I want to show you some
interesting data about the opposing
hormone now very few people know about
this but in nature all vitamins are
synergistic they work with other
vitamins vitamin D has a synergistic
vitamin called vitamin F in other words
they work together as a teacher taught
or type mechanism when one goes up the
other one goes down but the function of
vitamin D is to take the calcium from
the stomach and put it into the blood
the purpose of vitamin F is to take the
calcium from the blood and put it into
the skin tissues okay
and that is why vitamin F is a
protective mechanism against all types
of skin problems maybe you have never
heard about them enough it's the
polyunsaturated fatty acids so that
would be like the safflower oil the flax
oil the walnut and walnut oil sunflower
oil pumpkin seed oils or pumpkin seeds
fatty fish there e there is some
actually even some vitamin F in in
butter too there's also vitamin F in
Collar boil and there's there's one type
of food that you have a 50/50 split of
vitamin D and vitamin F and that would
be
cod-liver oil which your grandmother was
correct so so those vitamins work
together now vitamin D is the Sun milk
products cream cheese raw milk and then
we have the vitamin F this is more
saturated fats these are unsaturated
fats okay so they work together now if
you're deficient in vitamin F you will
get hives you will get thick skin like a
farmer that's out in the Sun so long his
skin becomes very very very thick and
that is because you're getting all this
vitamin D vitamin T toxicity which
automatically reduces your vitamin F
which automatically drops your calcium
in the skin and leaves you vulnerable
for sunstroke sunburns all sorts of skin
problems so here's here's the problem
what you want to do is you want to
consider that they always have vitamin F
with vitamin D hives muscle cramps
sunburn it would be difficult to get
sunburn if you had enough vitamin F in
your bloodstream so if you actually do
have sunstroke go ahead and go in the
house and start consuming more flax oil
or something like that to get more of
that vitamin F and that will help you
heal that sunburn very very fast but
it's just a depletion of calcium to the
skin canker sores viruses come out of
remission when you're low in vitamin D
because vitamin I'm sort of item an F
okay so vitamin F goes down viruses come
out of remission because there's no
calcium there but to keep the virus in
check and keep it back in remission
so viruses come out of remission when
you're deficient in vitamin F that would
be canker sore so that's why the immune
system is very highly linked with this
the other interesting point is that
polio which is the virus always tend to
come come out outbreaks in the late fall
or the early early fall late summer
what else papillomaviruses come out in
the late summer the flu comes out in the
fall which is right after summer a lot
of virus outbreaks occur after the
summer months when you have all this
vitamin D and that's all it's doing is
depleting your vitamin F making you
susceptible for these viruses to come
out the virus is already in there it's
just coming out the other thing is the
cervical cancer which is viral related
cancer of the cervix that those
outbreaks come out in the late summer
which I just find that being an
interesting connection I don't know if
that's a fact but it sounds like it
correlates so this is the relationship
make sure that you balance it out and
understand this because you don't just
need vitamin D you need vitamin F to
keep the whole thing working and now you
understand how it all works and so make
sure that you consume a lot of these
omega-3 fatty acids in your diet and
that will kind of keep you out of
trouble so the other thing I want to
mention is that it's not as simple as
just taking vitamin D it could be you
don't have any bile so if you don't have
bile you need bile salts to be able to
digest the the vitamins the fat cyber
vitamins so you can start pulling in the
vitamin D in the bloodstream and there's
really nothing wrong with being out in
the Sun as long as you have vitamin A to
protect you and that way it'll keep the
calcium in there as well so you want to
take all this data and look at the whole
picture not just like this like through
a little microscope and so that's kind
of the holistic view I hope you enjoyed
it
and write down any comments about it
below and I will see you in the next
video